prepare to disintegrate some Jawas and
the best eggs you've ever had because
just three days after the first episode
premiered we have episode 2 of the
mandalorian and it is [ __ ] awesome
you're gonna want to stick around for
the entire video because I'll be
breaking down the whole episode with all
its Star Wars Easter eggs and new
details on what could be in store for
the mandalorian and the little green one
known as the child so here we go we pick
up shortly after the events of episode 1
with the Mandalorian taking the child
through a deserted chasm and if we know
anything about chasms they're usually
perfectly safe in episode 1 I was
curious whether the child was being held
aloft by the force or if it was the
machine itself and this episode answers
that question when we see the
Mandalorian able to program its
movements the two of them are travelling
back to the Mandalorian ship the razor
crest so that the Mandalorian can claim
his reward one of the things I love
about this intro scene are the little
cutaway shots of these new sand
creatures it's just a small detail but
it adds so much to the world-building
aspect of the show they want to show us
these unique worlds with their own
creatures now we still don't know what
planet this is I've heard some people
suggest Tatooine but I don't think it is
based off two criteria one we haven't
seen the binary Sun and two the Jawas we
meet later although native to Tatooine
wear different colored robes regardless
we simply don't have any definitive
proof but I think if it were tattooing
they would have made it obvious because
fans would just go nuts one of the cool
things you may have missed are these
shadows in the background foreshadowing
the Mandalorian getting ambushed by a
group of bounty hunters we know their
bounty hunters by the tracking fob
similar to the ones the Mandalorian was
given an episode one to track his
bounties they are part of the trend
ocean race although the makeup is
considerably better than when the
species made its first appearance in
episode 5 the Empire Strikes Back with
the bounty hunter Bossk
both are reptilian in nature and have
these almost claw-like hands I also want
to quickly mention the great detail the
costume designers have put into the
Mandalorian suit the red display panel
looks like it's practical not CGI which
I love
and since the panel is on the right side
it's likely instrumental in working his
flamethrower which we'll see used later
on in the episode but who sent this team
of three bounty hunters could it be the
client just wanting to make sure he gets
the asset could it be the person or
persons who sent the bounty hunter droid
IG 11 last episode or could it be in an
entirely different party we haven't yet
met unfortunately other than the
tracking fob the bounty hunters offer no
real clues as to who sent them we also
get to see the Mandalorian really put
into work his am band faze blaster using
it at close range to shock his opponents
as well as long-range to completely
disintegrate his enemies as will later
find out when the Mandalorian goes Jawa
hunting the blaster component needs to
be reloaded after each shot these ammo
rounds can be found in the shell casing
type rounds on his knees and chest after
the battle the Mandalorian and child
rest along the gorgeous tinge of the
Setting Sun the Mandalorian is busy
trying to cauterize his wound the child
even gets out of his pod out stretching
his hands seemingly trying to heal it
but is put back when the Mandalorian
notices him we should definitely add
healing powers as a potential ability
the child can use and that will likely
see this in upcoming episodes we also
get a glimpse at the inside plating of
mandos armor which resembles more like
the inside of a computer than armor with
all the gadgets he has going on it's not
a surprise making their way back to the
razor crest the Mandalorian finds a
group of Jawas completely dismantling
his ship next to it is a giant sand
crawler vehicle which you might
recognize from a new hope these mobile
fortresses were used both as transport
and shelter and could fit an entire Jawa
clan they even contain magnetic suction
tubes for sucking in droids and scrap
into the cargo hold now correct me if
I'm wrong but I believe this is also the
first time we've seen the cockpit of a
sand crawler which seems to operate more
on a system of levers than advanced
technology there's even this large tube
here used to communicate to other areas
of the ship and let the Jawa massacre
begin the Mandalorian goes to town
disintegrating several jalwa as they
flee with his ship parts he runs after
it with the child following in his pod
this whole action set piece was a ton of
fun
and I have to say it feels very Star
Wars even the sound effects news when
he's hit over the head with random
pieces of scrap are borderline cartoony
in nature although I'm a bit
disappointed there was no Wilhelm scream
the Mandalorian ends up using his
grappling line to climb the side of the
crawler the grappling line is
traditionally an anti Jedi weapon with
cords strong enough that even a
lightsaber can't penetrate if used
accurately it can even be used to
retrieve a lightsaber directly from the
hands of its wielder unfortunately for
the Mandalorian when he makes it to the
top a flock of Jawa wait what do we call
a group of Jawa is it just Jawa jalwa
knees Juwan oh man well they totally
shocked the crap out of him his body
falling over the side onto the desert
sand below the Mandalorian investigates
what's left of his ship it's been
completely gutted like even his engine
does a little fart inside we see his
weapons cache from Episode one has also
been pilfered and look at this oh my god
it's so cute with this little one now to
take care of the Mandalorian heads back
to quiesce outpost there's some gorgeous
travelling shots with cinematography
done by Barry Baz I DeWine who also
worked on rogue one even the transitions
follow in these Star Wars traditions
utilizing feathered wipes to illustrate
the passing of time back at quills
outpost quill is surprised that this
child was the cause of all this fuss
whatever significance this child holds
must be of great importance for an
entire platoon of mercenaries to have
guarded it as well as bounty hunters
tasked with its retrieval will makes a
fun remark that because this green thing
is a child it's good that the mando
brought it back alive even though it's
fifty years old there's just one problem
how is he gonna get off this planet
quill suggests they barter with the Java
which I'm sure they won't take too
kindly to since he just killed a bunch
of their people but if the Mandalorian
is to make it off this planet he'll need
to get those parts will here also gives
him a tool which helps him fix his
grappling line his entire armor has been
put through the wringer these last two
episodes oh and who can forget that
child just straight up swallowing this
fog creature Tim through torrential
downpour quill navigates a blerg pulling
one of those levitating scrap haulers
and in this next shot you can see the
attention to detail even the ground has
pools of muddy water from last
it's rain the job will have set up shop
here and upon realizing the mandalorian
is there they go on high alert and
rightfully so they really don't like you
yeah he killed like six of their people
the Jawa demand that the Mandalorian
drop his weapons but he says they're
part of his religion and he'd be right
the Mandalorian religion is one of war
they even believed that to wage war was
to be divine in modern times however
their religion has become more secular
and pragmatic the word manda describes a
collective soul and those who do not
believe in the faith are considered dar
manda or soul lists
we're only on episode 2 but with the
mandalorian growing up as a foundling or
orphan who knows what spiritual or
religious upbringing has shaped the way
he sees the world
at first the Jawa are willing to trade
his parts for best car steal but that's
a deal breaker
as well as the child who they offered to
exchange and if there's one thing we've
learned about the mandalorian here it's
that he's not that great at negotiations
you understand that with nothing really
to exchange the Jawa say that if he can
capture an item known only as the egg
they will give him back his parts he's
dropped off near the entrance to a
creepy s cave and checks his gear I'm
really enjoying how they're showcasing
all of his gadgets including this helmet
mounted flashlight which they never show
if it comes out of his helmet or if it's
some sort of accessory inside the cave
are a bunch of Bones Star Wars has a
history of bones in caves this is a lair
of a creature known as a mud horn at
least according to the official
subtitles a hairy rhinoceros type
creature who really is just trying to
protect its young kind of like how the
Mandalorian is trying to protect this
young one after a few blaster shots
which only seem to piss off the mud horn
more the Mandalorian is knocked out into
the open where the majority of their
battle takes place both the flamethrower
and grappling line are ineffective
against its hard outer exterior the mud
horn prepares for one final blow against
our hero the Mandalorian even defending
himself with this dinky knife when
suddenly the child uses the force to
levitate this giant creature the amount
of power required for this is so great
that it only lasts a few seconds before
the child passes out giving the
mandalorian enough time to stab the
creature
side with what appears to be a Cal
dagger the traditional Mandalorian
dagger usually forged from Bess quraían
what I find really interesting here is
that this creature dies shortly after
was this tiny dagger able to kill the
beast or is there something else at play
here did the child injure the Beast
in another way when the Mandalorian is
driving back with the part squeal ass of
the child was injured to which the
Mandalorian says I don't know at least
not physically I want to know your
thoughts about this below since it seems
like a huge stretch that this tiny
dagger was able to bring down this giant
beast and holy crap that armor is gonna
need to be cleaned
well that 'n fixed it's still sparking
with the mud horn defeated the
Mandalorian is able to retrieve the egg
which looks like it's covered in thick
hair and mando catches the Jawas just in
the nick of time before they were going
to leave he gives them the egg which
they then proceeded to open and feast on
roll wheel and the mandalorian get to
work on the ship which he says will take
a few days to put together and we get
this sweet montage of the two of them
going at it
[Music]
with the razor crest finally fixed the
mandalorian offers squeal part of the
reward which he turns down his reward
was having peace restored to the valley
the Mandalorian even offers him a
position as a crew member on his ship
which has also turned down and the fact
the Mandalorian is looking for good crew
members means will likely acquire a few
as this season progresses the mando says
goodbye to quill and takes off into
space with the child back to retrieve
his bounty from the client but with
several people searching for this kid
he'll undoubtedly have some trouble
along the way if you look at the second
trailer for the season released by
Disney about three weeks ago we see this
shot of the razor crest being chased in
space but we can't be sure when it
occurs in the season we also have the
razor crest touching down on what I
think is grief cargas planet from
episode 1 the same plan that the client
is on but these shots of Giancarlo
Esposito is yet to be named character
combined with the type of building in
the back here lead me to believe the
Mandalorian will either be
double-crossed or ambushed by them while
returning back the armour of the storm
troopers here are way cleaner than those
employed by the client so it looks like
the Mandalorians troubles will stem from
Giancarlo whom I guess will be the main
villain of the season make sure to force
meld that like button and subscribe for
more Mandalorian videos I'm planning to
do the whole season so be sure to put
that bell on I also want to hear what
you think will happen next in the
comments below you can also follow me on
Twitter at ding story y team until next
time remember daddy loves you very much